[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv et 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
discuter et débattre sur des sujets qui
font l'actualité
ils sont sous le feu des projecteurs
depuis plus d'un an les soignants qu'ils
soient médecins infirmiers ou encore
aides soignants le monde de la santé est
très souvent plébiscitée par les lycéens
alors quel attrait dans les yvelines on
en parle avec nos invités patricia
thériault directrice de l'institut de
formation en soins infirmiers mgen la
verrière loïc josseran vice doyen de
l'ufr de santé de l'université
versailles saint quentin et et marc
antoine étudiante en licence 1 à l'ufr
de centaines de lui des excuses
bonsoir à tous les trois bonsoir bonsoir
alors sur parcours sup un candidat sur
cinq a fait au moins un voeu en lace la
licence avec option accès santé un sur
dix a choisi au moins parce le parcours
spécifiques accès santé en 2020 les
voeux représenté 3,9 pour cent en 2021
ses 8,5 pour cent loïc josseran c'est
une tendance que vous voyez aussi l ufr
simone veil santé de l'ue vs qu à bâle à
nous la voyons effectivement
complètement on et j'allais dire noyé
sous les sous les candidatures
habituellement nous en avions un peu
moins de 8000 c'est ce qu'ont observé
depuis plusieurs années là cette année
on a dépassé en arrive quasiment à 10000
donc ce qui est ce qui est ce qu'il ya
un chiffre assez important ce qui
représente quand même une augmentation
de quasiment 25% ce qui est important et
sur les autres formations en avignon en
place cette année une licence d'accès
tourner vers le ver là les métiers de la
rééducation qui n'ait été rapide car
c'est la première avec s'est ouvert aux
avions 100 places on a eu près de 8 600
candidatures cia il ya donc ce qui fait
au total près de 2000 demandes sur sur
la seule ufr en matière de santé
c'est quelque chose dont vous vous
attendiez à laquelle vous attendiez nous
attendions éventuellement un rebond mais
de cette importance non honnêtement
danser c'est parce que c'est derrière
faut bien voir que c'est compliqué à
gérer un c'est nous avons fait le choix
de lire tous les cv et toutes les
lettres de motivation qui nous
parviennent il n'y a pas de traitement
automatisé elles ont été lus par des
universitaires de l'ufr donc on se les
est répartie en ont fait tous un peu
plus d'une cinquantaine
elles ont été lus l'ont été nos pl on
était donc c'était parce que simplement
audois aux lycéens qui s'engagent ils
font ce choix là et ce sont des choix
qui sont là et il faut choisir aussi les
les étudiants malheureusement on est
obligés de le faire mais il faut les
choisir sur des critères objectifs et
pas juste sur des critères de notre parc
et marc antoine vous êtes vous-même en
licence alors la particularité c'est que
vous avez redoublé c'est la possibilité
qui était donné que le pass est ce ça
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui l'année
2019 2020 on le sait a été complexe avec
le comte film home et vous avez pourtant
pas hésité à retenter votre chance
alors si j'ai longuement hésité parce
qu'en plus il ya eu la réforme donc pour
les doubles en paces ne savais pas trop
à quoi s'attendre
le nombre de places qu'on allait avoir
et c'est maintenant je pense que quand
on a une idée en tête et qu'on espère
enfin que c'est entre guillemets un
petit peu notre rêve d'être médecin ou
autre je pense que l'on n'hésite pas à
redoubler quand on est motivé
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé vous à vous
lancer dans ses études
alors moi je fais pas partie des
personnes qui sont passionnés depuis
tout petit et qui rêve d'être des
médecins par contre je voulais faire un
métier qui avait une utilité sociale
avec aider les personnes et surtout le
partenaire du rouet ou un ordinateur est
assez au fil de mes années de collège
c'est que j'ai bien aimé la biologie et
surtout tout ce qui tournait autour du
camp romain donc c'est ça que
naturellement je me suis dirigé vers la
alors il y a une autre profession de
santé qui attire notamment sur parcours
succès la première c'est les soins
infirmiers
patricia thériault il ya toujours de
l'engouement auprès des aspirants
infirmiers et infirmières oui cela ne
dépend absolument pas puisque par conçu
pour nous c'est la troisième année et
quand même cette année 10% des inscrits
sur sup sont venus s'inscrire sur les
instituts de formation en soins
infirmiers
donc c'est très très demandé je ne suis
pas si la crise qu vide a augmenté cette
demande là on peut faire cette hypothèse
malgré une formation toujours été quand
même depuis deux ans trois ans on le
voit toujours été très demandé je pense
que je rejoins est mal sur ces propos là
le souhait est jeune génération d'être
sur des métiers engagés dans la société
quelque chose d'important
vous accueillez 80 étudiants par
promotion est ce que il y a des listes
d'attentes est ce que comme monsieur
josserand et du sql ufr pardon santé du
vs q vous avez dû passer du temps sur
les candidatures comment ça s'est fait
chez vous parcours sur le vin comme nous
comme ce que disait monsieur jospin nous
a fait nous avons étudié toutes les
candidatures noté sur parcours sur une à
une avec tous les projets de motivation
associés et comme comme à lui est ce
qu'une nous avons fait des choix sur des
critères extrêmement précis les choix
lui et les choix seront faits sur le
groupement universitaire puisque 8,6 on
veut couper autour de l'univers
à 50 ans on l'ifsi de la hem suez et
sept autres et donc nous nous partageons
entre les huit ifsi la totalité des
dossiers de candidature et nous les
épluche on en a on l'a on l'a entendu
les chiffres de parcours sup le montre
vos propos le montrent ces des études
qui attire en outre chaque semaine on
interroge nos téléspectateurs cette fois
on voulait savoir si eux ils pensent que
les professions de santé attire les
jeunes et c'est plutôt le nom qui
l'emportent
loïc josseran c'est surprenant c'est lié
à peut-être une méconnaissance
de la profession ça me surprend un petit
peu je sais pas ce qu'en pense madame
thériault aimable et moi ça me surprend
parce que c'est que dès qu'on fait les
portes ouvertes dès qu'on fait les
manifestations il ya toujours du monde
qui vient il ya des jeunes il ya des
parents ce jour aussi et qui viennent
donc il ya toujours un engouement
cet engouement il est alors là il a été
énormément me saouler sous les feux de
la rampe
enfin magnifier je pense avec avec le co
vide et on a vu porté aux nues les
soignants etc
cependant pendant plusieurs mois
d'affilée mais il y à côté de ça il ya
un autre phénomène qui pour moi et on le
voit tous les ans et on voit même les
références parmi les étudiants ce sont
toutes ces séries télé très porté sur la
santé et qui elle aussi à tous les ans
découvre des vocations alors la
difficulté c'est que ces séries télé
malheureusement elles sont dans un monde
un peu idéale elles sont absolument pas
proche de la réalité terrain que peut
vivre un professionnel de santé
tout est beau tout finit toujours bien
il ya éventuellement une petite larme à
la fin mais voilà tout va bien dans le
meilleur des mondes
la réalité est super d répète à chaque
fois aux portes ouvertes aux étudiants
c'est la réalité elle est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça il faut être accroché
il faut avoir envie d'aider les autres
c'est pas toujours simple parce que je
ne dois pas forcément toujours envie
d'être aidés auxquels il faut il faut
complètement s'engager c'est un métier
qui engage énormément et je ne le
retrouve pas et ne comprennent pas
forcément quand il s'engage au départ ce
qui fait qu'il ya malheureusement
beaucoup qui se lancent et qu'ils
arrêtent en cours de route ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne voit pas on voit
l'afflux qui à l'entrée malheureusement
on ne voit pas là un certain nombre
d'étudiants qui quitte ses formations
quelle qu'elle soit que ce soit médecine
pharma je pense que c'est la même chose
sur richie jeu j'ai moins cette vision
là mais il ya des jeunes qui abandonnent
parce qu'ils se rendent compte que ça ne
correspond pas l'idéal qu'ils avaient ou
à la réalité qui sans fantasmer qui s'en
était fait celle ci attire mais parfois
c'est un peu le miroir aux alouettes
ou bien l'avoir enlevé mais patricia
terios et des profils aussi d'aider des
jeunes que infirmiers on a une image n
pas celle du métier un outil comme en
france c'est tout à fait cela c'est
c'est ce sont des représentations qui
sont véhiculées par des tas de choses
les médias et l'actualité est bon depuis
depuis 2020 mais aussi les séries télé
dont parlait monsieur jospin
d'autre part il y à 7 pour les
infirmières en tout cas cette
représentation que voilà il faut on a la
vocation donc comme on a la vocation est
bien cela suffit en soi la réalité et le
principe de réalité rattrape vite les
les étudiants qui entrent la réalité
elle est différente elle est l ai cru
elle est humaine
elle est engageante sur le plan du
travail
elle est engageante sur le plan
personnel elle et voilà c'est que ce
sont des formations et je pense que
matinée toutes les formations sont et se
retrouve qui kir mule qui remuent
personnellement un au delà de
l'apprentissage théorique et clinique i
à l'apprentissage d'un métier qui est un
métier de la relation humaine et qui est
fort difficile à faire pas impossible
non pas impossible mais en tout cas en
tout cas en ces gens exigeants monsieur
jose quand vous vous souhaitez réagir
non je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
que dit madame madame thériault mais je
pense que si si et mam l'a pas
d'ailleurs entendu dire à la fac j'ai
pour habitude de dire quand j'accueille
les étudiants qu'un malade c'est pas
forcément sympathique ça pue ça meurt et
que c'est compliqué quoi voilà donc une
fois et je le dis aux portes ouvertes de
la même façon je le dit à qui veut
l'entendre c'est malheureusement une
réalité est qu'il faut pas méconnaître
et il faut absolument que tous les
étudiants quelle que soit la profession
de santé est vraiment je vois je met
tout le monde sur la même sur le même
plan à presque toutes les professions de
santé sont confrontés à cette réalité là
et à la même on la vit tous en tant que
professionnels de santé donc ya pas deux
y'a pas de problème là dessus donc c'est
c'est eh oui c'est exigeant où il ça
nécessite en août ans un très beau mais
tiers je veux absolument pas non plus
terrorisée emma où tous les jeunes qui
voudraient se lancer c'est absolument
pas mon propos c'est vraiment mais il
faut avoir conscience et il faut
regarder aussi honnêtement c'est propre
ses propres limites ses propres
aspirations et jeudi régulièrement aux
étudiants qui a des tas de façons d'être
altruiste à des tas de façons de d'aider
les autres sans pour autant se lancer
dans les métiers de la santé directement
il ya des tas de façons de faire de la
santé sans forcément être professionnels
de santé on peut on peut faire de la
santé de de dizaines et de dizaines de
façons différentes en étant utile aux
autres sans forcément au tour en étant
autant dans un rayon d'un mètre
cinquante autour d'un lit double
alors on l'a vu le métier et diffuse les
métiers de santé sont difficiles mais
les études le sont aussi
on a cette image des études de médecine
qui sont dures longues exigeantes et
marc antoine est ce que ça vous a un
petit peu effrayés ont parlé des défis
mais des séries hippocrate première
année qui représente un petit peu c'est
notamment cette première année de
médecine
honnêtement en sortant le terminal je
m'attendais à ce que l'armée rallye ce
soit compliqué et hydra dg paille
énormément de surprises au final je m'y
attendais après forcément on a toujours
un petit peu d'appréhension parce
qu'aujourd'hui j'étais heureux sur un
ultime forcément un peu d'appréhension
pour la suite les stages et ferrat mais
c'est le côté qui motive et qui rend la
chose un petit peu plus intéressante
quoi les dix ans ne vous effraie pas
mais je pense que quand on est préparé à
faire dix ans d'études
on connait la finalité donc au final les
affiches sont toujours récompensés et je
pense que c'est aussi le cas voilà passé
sans cerveau présente bien pour pour les
personnes chez qui ça se termine bien tu
donc quand tout le monde sait que l'on
va avoir plus tard c'est pas du tout des
mois suivants en finale mais loïc
josseran j'ai parlé des dix ans mais
c'est presque le minimum en médecine
c'est presque le minimum aujourd'hui un
message faut bien voir que ce sont dix
ans qui évolue c'est pas c'est pas 10
ans assis derrière derrière un bureau à
chacun ses 10 ans où on va être pour une
grande partie à l'hôpital en fonction
j'ai médecin généraliste si on s'oriente
vers cette vers cette direction là ya
pas de ses 10 ans qui change
régulièrement dire qu'on va être au
début on des ondes et futurs vraiment à
la fac et puis ensuite on va passer une
partie de son temps à l'hôpital
et puis une fois candide interne passe
quasiment toutes séjourné à l'hôpital
donc ça change c'est évolutif c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose qui est figé où
on n'est pas étudiant comment
classiquement on pourrait imaginer on
est on est étudiant et en maintenant
acteurs de santé et déjà professionnels
de santé tout en étant un client c'est
la même eau chez chez sur la partie
formation soin d'affirmer que vous le
dire les sessions d'étude qui se font
beaucoup sur le terrain sur le tard
quelles que soient les professions de
santé d'ailleurs il ya on a la chance en
france qui est pas vrai partout
d'ailleurs d'avoir accès aux patients
aux wallons mais on reste aujourd'hui et
qu'on est un des derniers des rares pays
à avoir encore des étudiants qui peuvent
avoir accès aux patients il ya beaucoup
d'endroits vous bluffer sur les
mannequins
donc profitons de ça pour l'intérêt
qu'on peut amener aux étudiants et je
pense que madame thériault et à la même
approche que moi et oui juste avant
d'interviewer les études en soi affirmé
sont plus courtes mais non moins
exigeante ses 2100 heures de théorie et
2100 heures de formation clinique et ça
se fait en trois ans j'ai envie de vous
dire ce sont des études extrêmement
dense
vraiment c'est 3 en plein alors rassurez
vous il ya des vacances aussi
mais effectivement c'est une formation
qui est
en alternance professionnalisantes donc
à la fois des temps de théories sur
l'ici et des temps de cliniques sur les
stages et auprès des patients donc tout
ça en alternance pour sa mise en lien
fait que voilà et l'intérêt de ces
études construite de cette façon là
c'est que les temps qui sont proposés en
stage auprès des patients et dans les
équipes sont sont comment dire je dirais
nécessaire à l'appropriation d'une d'une
culture professionnelle d'une posture
professionnelle d'une d'un apprentissage
clinique évidemment ça cela va de soi
mais au delà une identité
professionnelle et que chaque élément
peut-être au travail anses h avec les
équipes en stage à 6 avec des coûts
pédagogiques donc une intégration des
samoa
d'un côté et de l'autre qui est faite
façon dont tout à fait régulière
on l'a à plusieurs reprises mentionné
nous sommes en pleine crise sanitaire et
les français se sont rendus compte que
les professions de santé et est plus
qu'essentiel depuis le début de la
pandémie et marc antoine comment ça
s'est passé pour vous êtes en l1 donc
pas de terrain est-ce que ce virus vous
a inquiété vous auriez voulu aller sur
le terrain quel était votre ressenti
quand en mars on est confiné et les
hôpitaux sont débordés
bah c'est vrai qu'en plus j'avais une
soeur va justement infirmières donc il
est question le terrain et bah quand
vous êtes en allant vous travaillez que
les courses et pas du tout qu'on crée en
soit on ne l'est pas du tout ce terrain
donc c'est vrai qu'on a qu'une hâte
c'est d'y aller et d'alerter les
professions de santé qu'ils étaient
fatigués qui parfois ne pouvait plus et
c'est vrai que ça donne envie d'y aller
et d'aider les côtés les personnes que
cela paraisse confiné on pouvait rien
faire et c'est assez frustrant
vous avez pu échanger notamment de voies
de serre ça vous a jamais dit ah je suis
peut-être pas fait pour ça ça va
renforcer votre vocation
oui tout à fait oui quand je la voyais
revenir dont il ya des jours c'était
était hyper heureuse parce qu'elle avait
sauvé des personnes etc de l'autre ça
l'était moins mais au final elle en tire
une bonne leçon et celle là énormément
formés et quand je la quand je la voyais
rentrer tous les soirs avec une accès
d'être que ce soit mon tour et que j'ai
sur le terrain et partir un peu à des
cours parce que c'est vrai que moi en
paces les courges
ça peut être un peu long à force mais
eux mais voilà justement loïc josseran
pas trop sérieuse que la crise sanitaire
a aussi modifié peut-être le profil
d'étudiants qui se lance dans les
fondations ce que par mission d'étude
mais en mesure d'être chanté aussi eu
des inquiétudes quel a été votre
ressenti depuis le début de la crise il
ya eu des on a tous vu ans avaient cessé
les étudiants en santé sont à l'image du
lendemain n'y a pas de y'a pas de secret
1 c on a eu ce qui était très volontaire
qui avait envie d'aider les autres etc
et puis on a vu ce qu'ils sont carapatés
il ya tout un salaire on n'est pas c'est
pas parce qu on est professionnels de
santé que dans ce coup on met absolument
le chevalier blanc sans peur et sans
reproche est prêt à faire front surtout
sur tous les fronts royal ya de tout et
on a vu de tous a vu des étudiants qui
avaient peur des internes qui avaient
peur donc il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de secret 1 c'est vrai qu'au début quand
on ne savait pas forcément d'ailleurs
comment tout ça allait tourner les
risques que ça représentait quand le
l'avenir nous semblait relativement
sombre il y avait il ya des étudiants il
ya des mânes des étudiants très avancés
comme les internes
or ils savent poser de réels problèmes
d'être d'être dans ce cas les
hospitaliers mais d'avoir le sentiment
de prendre des risques pour soi-même
allons aider les ans à ccc c'est sûr on
élimine professionnels de santé à
l'image du reste des individus et la
société
c'était ce qu'on les a mentionné
plusieurs fois les internes c'est ceux
qui sont sur la fin du cursus c'est bien
ça oui ce sont les les
les étudiants les plus vieux c'est la
partie spécialisation des études qui
commence à la fin de la saison
et qui suivant les spécialités du nord
entre 4 50 et 4 à 5 ans c'est vrai mais
il faut voir aussi qu'on a dû aussi
freiner des étudiants dans leur volonté
d'aller sur le terrain parce qu'un
étudiant qui est pas encore très avancés
dans sa formation finalement il va
prendre des risques pour lui m
il va faire prendre des risques à
l'équipe parce qu'il n'a pas forcément
un comportement qui est adapté notamment
non respect des règles d'hygiène dans la
compréhension du fonctionnement d'un
service donc ça peut parfois être contre
productif au contraire d'aller vouloir
absolument aider les autres il ya
parfois eu des situations de ce point de
vue là un petit peu un petit peu
difficile il faut aussi être faut aider
les autres mais il faut aussi être fort
mais ça reste les métiers qui sont
techniques et il nécessite quand même un
minimum avant d'être véritablement
lancer dans le grand bain et de quoi
réellement être être utile et du côté
12,6 mgen la verrière madame thériault
est ce que vous avez eu le même ressenti
qui a vu lui fr santé nous pour le
premier confinement nous avons donc nos
étudiants de preuves de 3e année donc ce
qui était plutôt sur la fin du cursus
sont partis directement sur les services
de soins pour le coup au tout début du
premier confinement en mars était un peu
compliquée dans certains services qui
n'avaient pas toutes les mesures de
protection nécessaires pour nos
étudiants et nous avons pu intervenir un
certain nombre de fois pour pouvoir
protéger nos étudiants nos étudiants ont
eu peur leurs parents ont eu peur nous
les avons coupe accompagner
individuellement au téléphone nous avons
eu beaucoup les parents téléphone pour
rassurer
c'était normal bon même s'ils étaient à
leur troisième année d'études
le cockpit ça faisait peur on ne savait
pas vers quoi on allait il avait peur
pour eux pour leurs familles pour leurs
proches
et donc c'est mais c'était quand même
une période extrêmement anxiogènes pour
autant pour autant les l'ensemble des
étudiants est allé en stage pendant
lagarde qui d'ailleurs on a évidemment
choisi les stages dans lesquelles nous
avons fléché nos étudiants bien sûr en
fonction de leur niveau de formation
pour autant je dirais que 90 % des
étudiants nous ont fait leur tour que ça
ce temps avait été un temps extrêmement
enrichissant extrêmement difficile parce
que des gens ont vécu des choses
extrêmement difficile extrêmement
complexe à traiter mais aussi un temps
extrêmement apprenant en termes
d'organisation d'unités coheed être
considéré comme maintenant dans l'équipe
évidemment il est soigné puis ce n'était
pas encore le laisse souffler troisième
ayant est accompagné pour un certain
nombre
donc ils ont trouvé ça enrichissant
extrêmement fatigant quand même nous
dans nos tripes six en tout cas nous
n'avons pas eu d'étudiants qui est lâché
la sphère donc à la fin la de 2-2
l'année scolaire 2019 2020
pour autant la rentrée 2020 nous avons
des étudiants qui nous ont dit à la fin
de leur premier stage de 2e année
notamment stop
j'arrête je suis c'était trop dur et je
me rends compte à quel point je n'ai pas
réussi à surmonter la difficulté
donc on a quelques étudiants qui ont
arrêté ou qui ont demandé un report de
formation puisque dans nos formations
cela est possible pour stopper réfléchir
à leur orientation ou revenir pendant le
temps qu'il le souhaite jusqu'à trois
ans donc voilà nous avons eu à gérer
cela mais je dois dire que aidant les
équipes de soins et dans les équipes
pédagogiques
vraiment il ya eu un travail remarquable
de fait
en termes d'accompagnement des étudiants
vraiment a suivi individuel un suivi de
groupe que nous avons mis en place
évidemment de façon virtuelle et puis
continue tu pédagogique qui a été
assurée tout le temps en a tout
transformé et les équipements ça c'est
vrai dans toutes les formations je crois
de santé les équipes ont été hyper
créatif ont transformé leurs modalités
pédagogiques et voilà je pense que
c'était difficile mais collective nous
avons réussi
on le voit c'est un métier de passion
c'est un métier de vocations j'aimerais
terminer avec vous et marc antoine vous
venez d'obtenir votre licence unique
vous avez réussi
comment vous voyez votre avenir vous
vous destinez vers quoi quel serait
votre profession de rêve
votre filière peut-être plutôt que votre
profession oui ben alors si on nous
demande aujourd'hui je dirais plus la
gynécologie à la procréation et ses
terrasses dans quelque chose qui me
plaît énormément
maintenant je pense que je vais
découvrir pleins d'autres spécialités
avec mon stage et surtout tout se joue
en 6e année donc je pense que il faut
pas partir avec mon idée précise ce
qu'on risque d'être déçu à la crainte
donc un bon moment j'ai pas forcément
non plus de préférence ouverte à tous
mais verrait bien et si aujourd'hui un
jeune de 16 ans 17 ans approchent
viens vers vous pour savoir s'il faut
aller en médecine qu'est ce que vous lui
dites pas tout dépend de ses motivations
comme les bonnes motivations s'il veut
travailler dans la santé sauver des
personnes
oui maintenant si la doutre motivations
moins concrètes
je dirais pas peut-être pas faut
vraiment être co pour tenir je pense que
c'était compliqué donc si on n'a pas les
bonnes motivations je suis honnêtement
je sais pas comment les personnes
peuvent tenir donc voilà si les
passionnés par la médecine que eelv
absolument soigner les gens expérience
je dirais pas mais vas-y enfonce fonce
je vous propose qu'on s'arrête sur ces
mots c'est la fin du set une société
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
temps deschamps sur un nouveau sujet
d'actualité
[Musique]